and now please welcome tonight's host
from the symbolic world podcast
jonathan pageau
[Applause]
welcome everybody i am very excited
because for the first time jordan
peterson is in montreal
it is the first time that he's speaking
here jordan has lived here he lived here
for eight years
he was at mcgill and he loves this city
and so it's really great to have
everybody here to uh to listen to him
speak
i want to um
rewind you in my life to 2015.
this is before jordan peterson was
famous he was a psychologist at the
university of toronto
and i was driving down the road and i
was listening to the cbc
and
i don't know i was just getting my son
at his friend's house on one evening
and there's this conference on on the
cbc
and here's this professor
and uh he's saying things that i am not
used to hearing on the cbc
the way that he was speaking the
references that he was making
he was going through solzhenitsyn and
milton and dostoevsky he was talking
about the nature of reality
using words like logos which you usually
don't hear
on the radio
i was
really surprised i was very surprised
because
he was saying things that were
connecting to something that i was
already thinking and this is an
experience that i've heard many people
say about jordan's work
which is that when they hear him he's
expressing something that they had on
the tip of their mind that they could
almost see that they could kind of
perceive and jordan is able to bring it
together for them in a in a more
succinct and
very powerful way
and i was so excited that i would i was
hitting the steering wheel i was like
screaming in the car i am not like that
this is not usually the way that i act i
was so excited that i i went to get my
son and all i could think about was what
i was what i'd heard on the radio i
couldn't believe it i got home you know
i'm online on google who is this jordan
peterson fellow i find him u of t you
know he's a professor of psychology
start listening to some of his lectures
and every lecture i'm astounded at the
way in which he's talking about the
world and especially for me what was
fascinating was that he was giving
he was helping the secular world
understand what some of the religious
patterns some of the mythology some of
the rituals that we engage with what it
is
that they could mean for them
what why do they make sense why do we do
these strange things like have rituals
why do we you know how why do we have
these strange stories that when you look
at them on the surface are completely
absurd he was really helping people to
gather that together
so i was so excited i wrote him a little
email and uh and i said uh thank you so
much for everything you do and i sent
him a link to a talk that i had given
talk that i had given at a university
also at a college in in ontario
at king's university i think
and
i was talking about similar things as
jordan
in that conference i was talking about
the problem of complexity and how you
know
how patterns come together and manifest
certain realities
but you know i just said i'll just thank
him because i i like i said i've never
done this before so i write him i'm like
thank you so much
and uh the next day i get an answer nice
little answer you know thank you so much
for your your message with a link to a
few more videos
but then two hours later
he calls me
i did not expect that either he and and
i was
as much shock as i was experiencing i
felt like on the end of the phone he
also had the same kind of shock because
he had detected in the things that i was
talking about
similar
patterns to what
was interesting him
uh and so since then since that moment
in 2015 jordan and i have been having an
ongoing conversation
conversation about the pattern of
reality conversation about
how complexity relates to the question
of religion
and uh
because he was coming to montreal jordan
said why don't we
why don't we try to continue this
conversation together so tonight with
jordan that is what i hope to do we'll
be going through
the different arguments about the
question of the pattern of reality of
how complexity comes about and how it
moves into all the way that we act how
we decide what is good and how we move
into the good so i'm i'm super excited
to have jordan with us and i'm really i
know he's excited to be in montreal so
everybody please welcome dr jordan
peterson
[Music]
thank you thank you
yeah well it's great it's great to be
here it's such a it's always such a
thrill for me to come to montreal this
is such a great city i loved living here
and we haven't been here for i don't
know five years or six years i have lots
of friends here my
my former advisor and business partners
here he's in the audience tonight robert
peel
bob was one of the people who helped
design the self-authoring program and
understand myself program and got lots
of old graduate student buddies in the
audience tonight so that's pretty fun
and i wish i could go out and walk
wander around the streets and see how
the city's doing but it looked great
when we came in today so i'm really
happy to be here and thank thank all of
you for coming and
and i'm really happy to be talking to
jonathan as he pointed out we've been
conversing seriously
with a variety of other people too
including bishop baron and john verbaki
in particular i just jonathan came up to
my house in toronto
a week ago a week ago oh yeah not very
long and we had a three-hour
conversation with professor verveiki at
the of the university of toronto and
and that went really well we're going to
really set on youtube at some point in
the relatively near future and
and so we're hammering out the same
problems in some sense from different
perspectives and that's quite fun and so
i thought
it would be a good opportunity
to
i like to use these lectures or these
opportunities to push my thinking on a
particular question farther than i've
been able to push before you know i
don't like to give the same lecture and
i like to discover some something new
and jonathan's a really good person to
talk to when you're trying to discover
something new especially on the symbolic
front and we've had quite a
fruitful interaction
especially about ritual i would say and
and
and traditional belief
and and the ideas of of traditional
not just christianity it's broader than
that jonathan is very well versed in
post-modern theory which is extremely
helpful and also in in cognitive science
as well as
deeply read theologically and a great
artist you should check out his website
he's really something he's made some
lovely pieces for us
so
well so away we go thank you very much
for agreeing to do this and again thank
you all for
coming i hope we have a bang-up evening
that's the plan man
so one of the things that prompted your
foray into religious thinking there are
different
different venues that you kind of
brought you into it but one of them was
definitely the problem of perception
that is the man in which humans perceive
and the
the place where cognitive science was
coming and realizing the limit of
perception or at least how
objects in the world aren't
just self-evident and that there's a
process by which we're able to come
together and the way in which the world
kind of shows us or manifests to us how
it is that we're supposed to inhabit it
so maybe you can start with that and
talk a little about that okay so
we can hit that from a variety of
different perspectives i mean the first
problem the cognitive scientists really
stumbled across and and the ai types who
are developing robots same thing and the
postmodernists the literary critics they
all run across this problem at the same
time which was that
any reasonably complex environment is
susceptible to a near infinite number of
interpretations and so when you hear the
post modernist say things like uh
well there's no fixed meaning for a text
which is something they really started
to understand i would say
really in the 1960s they're actually
right you know you think about uh
shakespearean play or a biblical story
well how many interpretations are there
of hamlet or of the story of cain and
abel
well there's an indefinite number of
interpretations maybe one for every
reader now there's some overlap because
we can commonly understand the stories
but
well if there's that many
interpretations
which one's right
and if none of them are right well then
are none of them right
and is there even any such thing as
right in that situation and so that's
the problem with textual
analysis and then in the real world
outside of text let's say
every visual scene is incomprehensibly
complex there's an indefinite number of
ways of seeing everything and this is
partly why we don't have general purpose
robots is because
ai engineers originally believed that
the problem
of robotics would be the computation of
action in the world but it turned out
that the problem of robotics was seeing
the world and that really shocked
everyone because when you look at the
world it's like well there it is you
know no problem you just open your eyes
and bang there are the objects and
yeah they're objects it's like well how
many of them well you could get lost in
the details of this carpet if you were a
photorealist painter you know you could
take just a section of the carpet and it
would take you maybe three weeks to
paint it in a high resolution manner and
even then you wouldn't have captured
anywhere near the detail and you'd only
have done it under one condition of
illumination and that's just a fragment
of a visual scene
and so
i started to get
extremely interested in this problem
which was the problem of attention how
do we reduce the
indefinite multiplicity of the potential
landscape of perceptions to the
self-evident things that we see
and the answer to that turns out to be
extremely bizarre
partly it's uh
well we don't see objects we see meaning
and we infer objects and that's quite
the bloody revelation when you start to
understand that because you know
modern people atheistic materialist
types they think what's sort of a dead
world
intrinsically and you overlay a meaning
on top of that and that's a secondary
overlay because the object perception is
primary and
it's not real the meaning it's like that
isn't how your brain works you see
meanings so for example with little
children
there's this experiment for example
called a visual cliff
if you if you take a
baby who can crawl and you put imagine
uh
a table like this and then another table
the same
set here and then a plate of glass
between them if you have the baby crawl
towards the
visual cliff
the baby will stop and the reason for
isn't the reason isn't that the baby
sees
like an objective pattern and thinks oh
no i can fall
they see a falling off place
and then they maybe they can infer some
common objective pattern out of that but
we see meanings
our primary element of our perception
is meaning mapped right onto our body
and that's
that really upends the whole in some
sense the whole empirical
notion of the way that we act in the
world the whole rationalist enterprise
although less that
um
and it poses very strange
epistemological questions so that's
questions about the theory of knowledge
but also very strange ontological
questions so for example if you're a
darwinian think okay well we evolved to
perceive the world
in a manner that's accurate enough to
ensure our survival
and that's about as accurate as it gets
in some sense if you're a darwinian well
we perceive the world through stories
actually like technically well does it
does that mean that the world is a story
or if not what does it mean
and the answer to that is it's not so
obvious and one thing that has become
obvious that jonathan and i have talked
about a lot is that it's clearly the
case that we
see the world through something that
when we describe it is a story so you
prioritize your attention
through a structure of value
and you can't see unless you do that
and so that even means that the
objective world and this is something
the post-modernist also kind of pointed
out the objective world isn't even so
clearly objective
not not in the way we thought because
you can't even see objects except
through a hierarchy of value
and so we've talked a lot about what
what that hierarchy of value might
might be and you've hit that
particularly from a more theological
perspective well one of the surprising
thing that comes out of it is the idea
that we are aiming when we're acting
that is in the world when we're moving
when we're doing things we're always
kind of aiming towards the good and
avoiding
the bad we could say and that actually
becomes in a certain manner the
definition of how we perceive objects
themselves right like if i see an apple
without even thinking about it i'm
always asking myself is it a good apple
is it an apple that will reach its
purpose and when we say its purpose it's
actually our embodied human purpose that
is right i see an apple i'm asking
myself is it good to eat
right and then
well and you're also assuming then
there's a platonic element to that too
so like does it fulfill its function as
an apple which would be for us it would
be well it's
ripe and it's not rotten and it's
delicious and and then
the reason you see it
it's it's tied into an ethic and you
might say well how what kind of ethic is
it tied into it's like well do you want
to eat
and
do you eat because you want to live and
do you want to live because you think
living is worthwhile and to what end are
you devoting your life and you think
well none of that's there when i see an
apple and that's absolutely 100 wrong
all of that is there when you see
everything and so you're embedded in an
ethic of aim
and you can't organize your perceptions
with it without that and that ethic of
aim
fundamentally
the
the highest order aims or the most
fundamental aims you can use either
metaphors so the most basic things or
the highest things they are
phenomenologically religious in
structure and i mean that by definition
so like when you talk about the deepest
things
and so those would be the things that
move you the most or the things that are
your ultimate aim you're in
the landscape that produces religious
experiences when people are in that
domain
and that's
deeply rooted biologically so one of the
religious instincts for example is the
instinct that's associated with awe
and with the compulsion to imitate so
you know we maybe you imitate a hero you
know and the ultimate hero would be a
divine figure
and so that's why for example religious
people might talk about the imitation of
christ
but that experience of awe which you
might have when you look up at the night
sky
that's associated with pilo erection
which is the feeling of your hair
standing on end and
or chills running up your and down your
back which sometimes you'll feel for
example if you listen to music and
you're deeply moved by it and that is a
reflex that's probably 60 million years
old because it's the same reflex that
you when you see a cat when it sees a
dog you know maybe it's afraid it puffs
itself up that's pilo erection and does
that so it looks big and then it dances
sideways and it's the experience the cat
is having is something like the
experience of awe
and and that's not cognitive like that's
60 million years old it's really old and
it's a primary religious experience
and so and it's it's tied into
perception in an extraordinarily deep
level partly because the things that
you're in awe of will be the things
towards which you aren't your
perceptions and your actions at the
highest level of organization
and so
that's actually what the awe experience
in some sense is for right it's to show
you
what is at the top of the structure that
directs your attention and that happens
with everything you do so in a way it
also becomes a way to understand two
aspects of the religious you could say
one which is the terrible aspect of it
this idea of this terrifying figure and
the other is the imitative part right so
you have this notion that uh
the the cat sees the dog or let's say a
young boy sees this giant warrior that
you know walks out in front of him and
he feels this sense of mixture of fear
of being impressed and of wanting
something from that or like wanting to
move up towards towards that yeah well i
think we've we talked about this in
relationship to the night sky
you know um
there's a there's a very famous image of
mary
that renaissance artists really went to
town on there's hundreds of paintings of
this so it's mary with her hair head in
the stars
and her foot on this on a serpent so
it's that serpent is the serpent in the
garden of eden or satan or evil and
the idea there it's an image of the
divine feminine and the idea is that
in order to protect the vulnerable from
evil
you have to be oriented
to the highest that the cosmos has to
offer and and the reason that's
assimilated to some degree to the stars
is because when you go out at night
and you look up at the heavens
well first of all notice that you're
looking up at the heavens that that
that's the term we use but that
you also do come face to face with the
infinite in in some real sense right i
mean you're looking out towards
the nearest thing to the infinite you're
going to encounter and that does produce
a sense of awe and that's in one
part of that that's a humility like the
cat might feel in relationship to a dog
but in another thing it's a call to
imitate even the cosmos because
along with that sense of being
awe inspired by the heavens and feeling
insignificant in some sense and humble
there's also a call to a greater form of
being and that's
you know one of the things human beings
did
because we were preyed upon and became
predators
one of the things we did was imitate the
predator you know and so
we were in awe of a predatory animal
like we still might be if you meet a
grizzly bear in the in the woods you
know it's you might freeze and you're
certainly going to attend to it but then
there's part of you that is deeply
called upon to imitate the
the
capacity for aggression of the predator
so that you can defend
your loved ones against predatory action
and some of that would be to be the
warrior that can fight off the grizzly
bear but then abstract it up into the
religious sense it would be to be the
ethical actor who can protect your
family from
um from unscrupulous
psychopaths you know
forces of malevolence that border on the
on the satanic and so
and that's all part of the ethical
enterprise and weirdly enough all of
your
acts of perception are necessarily
nested inside a structure that's
pointing to
what's what is at the highest or you're
incoherent those are the options
well that's a strange thing right
because you can say well maybe your
hierarchy of value isn't unified and
there's nothing at the top it's like
okay it's not unified well then you're
confused and if you're with someone and
your hierarchies of value aren't unified
then you are in conflict or you're
aimless or you're hopeless or you're
anxious or you're lost
that's the phenomenological consequence
of
lacking this united
pyramidal pyramidal ethic
so
you can't get away from the necessity of
this unless you want to live you know
aimless nihilistic confused hopeless all
of that
so we've got awe
and we've got the desire to imitate and
i think the third part that that i'd
like to to bring up and hear what you
want to you think about that is the
notion of celebrating
that's something that's something that i
don't know it seems to be particularly
human maybe there's examples of that in
the animal world i don't know but
there's something about humans which
celebrate and in celebrating what we're
doing is we're recognizing these
pinnacles whether it be celebrating a
great basketball player or celebrating
the the images of our nation or the you
know the unity of our family when we
come for thanksgiving there seems to be
something you you really helped me
understand
the relationship
the technical relationship between the
concept of worship and the concept of
celebration because you might say well
you know what does it mean to worship
and a cynical person would say it means
to believe things that no one but a damn
fool would believe
you know and that's kind of the
dismissive modern attitude but that
isn't what it means like
worship is
it has this celebratory aspect and that
is tied into this instinct to imitate so
if you have a sports hero
first of all he's a hero and he is
someone you put on a pedestal which
indicates a kind of right an elevation
towards the divine or towards the sky
metaphorically speaking and then there
is this compulsion to imitate and that's
no different than celebration and so
partly what's happening in a church
ceremony for example is that
an object of
celebratory worship is specified and in
the christian tradition that's christ
and which is a very strange thing
because of course he met
absolutely abysmal end and that's an
unbelievably complicated idea too that
that
the
the tragic the ultimately tragic element
of human life
is to be
voluntarily
apprehended in the deepest possible
sense
and that what that produces
paradoxically is a celebration and then
also a vision of the resurrection and
that's an idea that's so deep you you
could you can lose yourself in that well
we've lost ourselves in it for 2000
years because one of the things that
this attention problem brings about is
the question of sacrifice too and you
see it in the in religious ceremonies
but you realize that in order to exist
in the world you're constantly having to
sacrifice that is you have to sacrifice
the idiosyncrasies in order to be able
to grasp the the object because this can
be all kinds of things right i could be
a dog's true toe it could be could be a
million things but in order to be able
to grasp it i have to sacrifice
idiosyncrasies and i also have to
somehow let's say recognize it in its
highest form or kind of move it towards
its highest form and that seems to be
an aspect of religious thinking which is
actually part of attention which is
exactly well the sacrificial aspect of
attention in part is that whenever you
see something as that thing you
sacrifice the possibility of all the
other things it could be and that's
delimiting to a large degree you know it
hems you in but but that's also a relief
because you know how many bloody million
things do you want to attend to at one
time but so part of the reason you know
the idea of sacrifice
conscious idea of sacrifice emerges very
easy early on for example in the
biblical writings because the second
story in in genesis i think it's genesis
3 is that the canaanite is that the
canaan able stories genesis three or two
after genesis three genesis four okay so
it's very early on and there's this
insistence that so human beings are
already destined to work
as a consequence of the fall out of the
garden of eden but the cain and abel
story is specifically about sacrifice
and about the degree to which a
sacrifice has to be of the highest
quality so you have this one protagonist
abel
um who's a prototype for a mode of being
that stretches throughout history and
abel's sacrifices are
to the highest
to to that which is the highest
imaginable so he's aiming as high as he
can and they're genuine and honest and
the consequence of that is that
god smiles upon him let's say but that
his life is extremely successful he gets
everything that a sensible human being
would want and need and he's contrasted
with cain who's bitter
and arrogant and makes second-rate
sacrifices and you want to think about
that personally it's like
well did you give it your best shot
when when you failed and if the answer
is no it's like well
who are you trying to fool exactly you
trying to fool yourself
well good luck with that you're trying
to fool other people it's like well who
made you so smart and those them so dumb
and is that how you think about other
people you can just pull the wool over
their eyes and then is it more than that
do you think you can bend the structure
of reality and so you're gonna make
these half-witted sacrifices and that's
going to please god too and that's what
you believe
and you know cain is very annoyed that
his sacrifices aren't being rewarded and
he goes and talks to god and basically
calls him out and says something like
you know kind of stupid cosmos did you
make here
here i am breaking myself in half and
all the good things are going to able
it's like what's up with you which is
really quite the thing to do you know
and if you don't think people do that
you don't know much about them and god
basically tells them what people do that
all the time which is why it's an
archetypal story and god basically tells
cain that
he doesn't make good sacrifices he knows
that perfectly well
that he was tempted by bitterness and
arrogance and deceit
to enter into a consensual sexual
relationship with the spirit of vengeful
sin itself
which is a hell of an accusation
and well
you know these people who shoot up high
schools for example they dwell on their
sin for months or years
before they commit that act and they are
entering into a creative relationship
with temptation they let a terrible
spirit inhabit them and they enter into
a creative union with that
it's not it's it's they brood and you
know that's a sexual metaphor too and
they go to some plenty dark places you
have to go to some plenty dark places
before before you take an automatic
rifle out in an elementary school
and so if there's you don't think
there's any brooding in that in any
communing in a creative way with the
spirit of vengefulness and misplaced aim
then
you don't have much of an imagination
for that sort of thing and then you know
good for you but you better be careful
if you meet someone like that and so
there's this
this idea of necessary sacrifice right
and yeah and that sacrifice is necessary
for even for seeing for any like think
of a basketball player i like to always
bring it to something that at first not
religious at all for people to see what
we're talking about the basketball
player has to one sacrifice million
things that all his friends are doing
that are fun or that that he could be
doing he has to just he has to take away
all the idiosyncrasies and focus on one
thing and then he has to that's when the
able sacrifice comes in he has to give
his best if he doesn't give his best
then he won't
make it there's no way and so the the
sacrificial pattern enters into pretty
much any type of excellence or excellent
behavior we can yeah well and it also
might so it's integrally tied
with the problem of perception itself
and the fact that we have to sacrifice a
multiplicity of potential
interpretations or patterns of action to
focus on one but it's also integrally
associated with
the idea of the future
because to ensure that
you know people are aware of the future
in ways that animals aren't or animals
are only partially aware we're very
aware of the future and aware of our
mortal limitations in a manner that
seems unique to human beings and we
sacrif we constantly sacrifice the
present to the future that's actually
the definition of work
and that emerges very early on in the
biblical
narrative corpus the idea that humans
are destined to work but that also work
is the sacrifice of the present
and that's part of the fall in some
sense it's the sacrifice of the present
to the future and we regard that as the
hallmark of maturity fundamentally right
can you delay gratification well if the
answer is no it's well then you're two
can you delay gratification well then i
mean that technically um because
two-year-olds can't delay gratification
which
makes it very difficult for other people
to play with them for example
um if you can delay gratification then
you can work if your work if you can
work
then you're mature it's the definition
of maturity and responsibility and it
does pervade
it's so interesting to see that it
pervades the act of attention itself and
that there's no because you know i used
to ask my students because i was trying
to figure this out i'd ask them a
question like well
why are you why are you writing this
essay or what are you doing when you're
writing this essay that's a better
question so you think what is someone
doing when writing an essay
and one answer is
say they're doing it on a computer well
they're moving their fingers up and down
and that's actually a really good answer
because that's not an idea right moving
your fingers up up and down that's not
an idea that's where your spirit meets
your body you're actually
moving
something physical and you you don't
really have consciousness of the
musculature or you know you don't know
how you move your fingers but you can do
it and so at the most the highest level
of resolution when you're writing an
essay you're moving your fingers and now
you know how to type and you have
automated structures for doing that and
then you're composing words and the
words are in phrases and the phrases are
in sentences and the sentences are in
paragraphs and the paragraphs are in
sections and the whole thing makes an
essay but then that's a subset of a
class and you want to grade for the
class because you want to pass the class
because you want to get your degree
but why do you want to get your degree
it's well maybe you're interested in
that field of study and you think being
a scholar is a good thing and you want
to have a job and so while you're
writing an essay you're
what are you doing preparing to have
your career and then
does that are you doing that because you
want to be a good citizen and a good
father perhaps good mother
and do you want to do that because you
want to be a good person
and are you mixed up in all of that and
but
so you're doing all of those things
well or badly at the same time all the
time with everything you do
all the time and there's no way around
that it can't be simplified the whole
structure has to be there
and that's another reason why we don't
have general purpose robots yet is that
they're just not embedded in that
ethic that stretches all the way up from
the most minute motor patterns of action
and perception to the highest possible
ethical striving and then the question
becomes two is like what's at the top
and that's the fundamental religious
question and
that
the idea of what's at the top has
transformed across the centuries the
ancient egyptians
they put
two things at the top they put a god
um known as osiris who is basically the
spirit of the state
so you could think about him as the
spirit of tradition and the problem with
osiris was that he was old and
anachronistic and willfully blind and
lost in the underworld all of those
things real problem and it's sort of
like
when everybody complains about how
corrupt society has become and how they
feel alienated from their culture um
that's all osiris fundamentally that's
that's how the egyptians represented it
and so that was one part of what should
be at the highest tradition and the
other part was horus and horus is the
famous egyptian eye and horus is a
falcon because falcons have great vision
and so horus is the spirit of living
attention and the egyptians believed
that the pharaoh who was sovereignty
embodied was the incarnation of the
union of tradition and vision and so
that's what they thought should be at
the highest which is and that's what
they symbolized by the gold cap by the
way on the pyramids and so because the
gold cap is
it's at the top of the pyramid which is
a
uh ethical hierarchy a pyramid and the
top is
qualitatively distinct in some sense
from the structure itself it's
it's because it's in the highest place
it's it's different than everything else
that is underneath it
and we all wrestle with the problem of
what should be in the highest place
there's no way of escaping that problem
and you might say well nothing is fine
you're polytheistic you're confused
you're all over the place you're
scattered
that's the consequence of not having
this unified internal structure and if
your society doesn't have it well then
you can't get along with people and
you're in conflict
and so these aren't none of this is
optional it's we're doomed to
well my new book is going to be called
we who wrestle with god and i would say
well because that's israel right that
that's the definition of the term israel
is we who wrestle with god which is so
interesting
and uh those are god's chosen people we
who wrestle with god
and it's because that's our fate we're
we're going to wrestle with ethical
issues period it doesn't matter if
you're atheistic or religious in fact
lots of people who are atheistic are way
more obsessed with religious ethics than
religious people are well they are right
because they well they are because and
and they're more honest about it
sometimes because they'll advance
genuine confusion and distress which is
appropriate
but it's not like they just ignore it
it's they're often so anti-religious
that it consumes their life it's like
well that's fine there wrestle away man
if you're wrestling with god it's like i
don't believe in him it's like yeah he
doesn't believe in you either but you
know
or maybe he does which would even be
worse
and so we have the we have the pyramid
and in the bible we have especially the
mountain we have a few structures like
that there's the mountain the mountain
of paradise in particular or the mount
sinai on zion we also have the temple
itself which has this structure in terms
of it's a
pyramid towards unity this invisible
unity or this transcended unity and so
the question is
what comes down from the mountain this
is because one of the things we talk
about is
how we most of the things we've been
discussing from the beginning and a lot
of the big discussion that's happening
is bottom up and i'm totally fine with
that but there is something which comes
down from the mountain let's say the law
but what is that how do you see that
what it is what kind of nominal or or
structural
power or authority comes down from that
hierarchy
well
one thing maybe before we address that
precisely maybe you could just run
through the sorts of things we talked
about in relationship to sacred
architecture and the relationship
between the sacred architecture and the
structure of of a perceptual or
cognitive category because that's
extremely interesting so so why don't
you lay out the this church structure
with the holiest of holy and this is
this is very common anthropological
structure so
most well the idea is that
just like jordan was talking about in
terms of multiplicity and the problem of
complexity we have that problem when we
act we also have that problem in space
that is how do we encounter space how do
we embody space and our spaces end up
being hierarchical right a house is a
hierarchical your house has a has a
porch where you meet strangers you know
you have an entry where you maybe let a
few people in you'll have your dining
room where it's more intimate ultimately
you have your bedroom when all where
only you and your lover will be in this
secret place so there's this hierarchy
of intimacy that we normally have that
you have to live with or else you'll go
crazy but you can understand that as
scaling up in terms of societies as well
where there were these spaces these
temples usually would have three
sections and there would be a section
that was more open in the jewish temple
for example you had courts for the
strangers courts for you know uh people
that were still kind of impure they
weren't supposed to go in then you had
people a court for the the israelites
then accord for the priest then
ultimately you had to place this one
invisible place that only one person was
allowed to go in and that's where they
would receive the revelation of god you
see the same thing with uh with moses
going up the mountain at the bottom of
the mountain all these crazy people
worshipping golden calves and then it's
kind of wild and crazy and as he goes up
there's this
let's say uh rushing away of
multiplicity the elders remain on the
mountain then he moves up and then he he
enters into that space alone so you can
see that space itself has that kind of
hierarchy and when you experience it
yourself you can do it go up a mountain
i always tell people if you want to
understand
what holiness is just go up a mountain
because
at the bottom of the mountain you see
idiosyncrasies you see little things you
see details you don't have a big picture
and as you go up the mountain that
picture starts to become clear and clear
and when you reach the summit of the
mountain you have you you have the
experience of seeing all reality in one
breath like in one moment and that is
really this kind of hierarchy of a
perception but it's also the hierarchy
of the good so we have the idea that
ultimately that's the same thing for
ethics that there is something there is
a good up there there's something which
binds them all together in that
structure
this is a difficult leap but that
structure manifests itself with every
act of perception you make so for
example
you know i can look at the scene i'm in
a lot of different ways i can look at
most of you are in the dark so i can't
see you very clearly but i can i can you
know see a bunch of people i can see one
person or i can see the arm of one
person or i can look at the
floor here or or i can focus on this and
you know by focusing on this i center it
i privilege it right i give it i give it
a sacred quality and you might think
well no you don't it's like yes you do
really because now you've determined
that
this is the most important thing that
you can do at this moment at in this
place in relationship to the entire
ethic that you inhabit and you can't see
this without doing that and if you get
it wrong you pay for it yeah well you
might spill it for example or if you're
driving and you don't end up focusing on
the right thing you you will die you die
yeah yeah yeah yeah and so it's it's
it's not it's not a theoretical problem
it's a real problem of structure it's a
very strange thing to understand that
you inhabit this sacred architecture
with every perceptual
act you undertake and and also
perception is an act by the way you know
you think well you just open your eyes
and then you see the world it's like no
that isn't how it works your eyes are
moving all the time if they stop moving
for more than a tenth of a second you
will go blind because the the cells
exhaust themselves and so there's all
sorts of little micro movements that
your eyes are making some of them
involuntary and some of them voluntary
without which you can't see and the act
of visual perception is very much like
the act of exploring something with your
hands which is why you know if you close
your eyes and someone hands you a cup
you won't be able to tell if it's
transparent or not but you can feel it
out and you can develop a pretty good
visual picture of the
of the of the object so you can see with
your hands and that's partly why kids
want to grab everything because it's
hard to see with just your eyes and if
you can add your hands to that it makes
it easier to see
and so and that's active exploration and
you're feeling out the world with your
eyes it's you're never a passive
recipient of a priory sense data so the
empiricists are just wrong and then the
rationalists have been arguing with them
for centuries because the rationalists
always presumed that
you you didn't just get raw sense data
you had to impose a a priory
interpretive schema on the world and
that's the difference between
rationalism and empiricism and the
rationalists are right although they
thought that was just rational and
that's where they were wrong so it's
it's it's not rational in in the same
sense that a reductive materialist
atheist would use that term
and so
it's very strange that the
structure of of sacred architecture say
duplicates the structure of cognitive
category and also the structure of
perceptual category so we inhabit a
temple
corrupt though it may be
with every
interaction with the world that we
undertake and that's really quite a
frightening thing to realize uh very
it's a very frightening thing to realize
when you really realize it it's like oh
oh oh this is real
and it's even worse than that it's like
it's the precondition for the idea of
reality itself which is that's really
real right i mean you've got real that's
nothing it's the precondition for
reality itself
that's
super real and you know to some degree
the the christian idea of the logos and
the greek ideas well is
the expression of
the recognition of the precondition for
the real itself and that's really
something to understand as well
you know scientists i talked to richard
dawkins when i was at oxford you know
and one of the things that characterizes
dawkins is that
dawkins believes that the truth will set
you free
that is not a scientific presupposition
that is a religious presupposition but
it also might be
the religious presupposition without
which science is not possible because
all the scientists i know who are real
scientists
they're un they abide by the truth to an
unbelievable degree you know if you're a
social scientist and you have a data set
in front of you
you know say
200 columns of 500 rows you know a
complex data set man there are a lot of
ways you can get that to talk to you
statistically
and you make thousands of decisions when
you're doing a statistical analysis and
every single one of those is an ethical
decision and one of the decisions is
well do i prioritize my career or do i
prioritize my pursuit of the truth
and so often those are antagonistic
because if you have a big data set you
want to discover something in it and
maybe there's nothing there and then
you've wasted two years and like that's
pretty hard on your career and so that
battle between career promotion and
adherence to the truth goes on with
every statistical decision and so much
of social science is just not true
because the incentive structures are set
up badly and so people will falsify
their
data with a million micro decisions and
produce nonsensical
patterns as a consequence it's all an
ethical enterprise and not just
nonsensical but dangerous like dangerous
for society as well oh yeah these have
consequences yeah well yeah yeah if you
falsify what hypothetically constitutes
objective truth that's it's it's it's
devilishly awful because you actually
harness the validity of science to your
to your own
self-aggrandizement or your own ideology
and that's happening that's happening
plenty at the moment folks
so yeah it's really bad
one of the things that you you've been
able to bring about as well is this idea
that of aiming or the notion of sin as
missing the mark let's say there's a
great quote by saint paul that says
everybody knows it says the wages of sin
is death but there's a manner in which
that's even technically
it seems like something that we could
defend like that if you do not aim
properly right so the wage of the the
price of not aiming property that's not
pessimistic enough yeah because death is
one thing but hell is another thing you
know and so hell is the place that you
go when you'd rather be dead yeah and if
you haven't been there well that's great
for you but but death wages
it's like a technical description of the
place where unity breaks down like that
you know when you die that's what
happens your body stops to cohere your
cells start to go their own way and
things start to break down and if we
don't aim properly then that's
death yeah well that's well that that
touches on another interesting problem
so
i talked to sam harris relatively
recently again it's about the fifth or
sixth time i've talked to him publicly
and uh
i i did it better this time one of the
problems with the discussions i had with
sam harris for those of you don't know
he's one of the world's most famous
atheists um and i suppose that's his
primary claim to fame um
well i'm not no i'm not being i'm not
being uh sarcastic about that like he
was well known with christopher hitchens
and richard dawkins and uh
um the the uh then it tough yeah bennett
the four of them the four
atheistic horsemen essentially and they
well that's what that's how they were
known and
he he he became very well known as a an
advocate for this rationalistic atheism
along with these other three and they're
you know they're pretty damn good at
defending it um
but i talked to harris and for the first
four or five times i talked to him i did
something i don't usually do when i talk
to people which is i was having an
argument i was trying to win i wanted to
establish a point because i believe that
the way he was looking at things was
wrong and that was my
role to
show how that was wrong and i don't do
that when i'm talking to people
generally generally what i do is listen
to them and try to figure out what they
think and the last time i talked to
harris that's all i did i just asked him
questions and we got way farther in our
discussion than we ever had and i found
out that with harris
he identified the
spirit of totalitarian certainty
with
the religious impulse so for him there
was no differentiation between those
things and so what harris is objecting
to when he objects to religion apart
from the meditative religion that he
practices um was
the
was totalitarian dogmatism of the
sort that might be responsible for
you know
social atrocity and so fine no wonder
you're against that it's like is that
the same as the religious enterprise
it's like no i'm afraid not that's not a
very differentiated analysis but i get
your point at least and then the other
thing harris wanted to do is
he wanted partly because he was so upset
about the moral relativism
that
threatens us let's say and that he
believed was responsible for such things
as the auschwitz nightmares that he
wanted to ground an ethic in objective
fact because the only thing he believes
is real is objective fact and so that's
his motivation now
that's problematic as far as i'm
concerned because of some of the issues
we already raised which is well
which objective facts there's like an
infinite number of them and that's
actually a fatal error that's a fatal
problem with your supposition now it's
complicated right because
you say well the wages of sin or death
you can take an ecological and
evolutionary view of that it's like
obviously
whatever ethic we use to organize our
behavior and our societies has to serve
the functions of let's say reproductive
fitness so there's got to be a
concordance between the domain of ethics
and the domain of evolutionary biology
let's say and then it's an open question
to what degree
you can use the findings of evolutionary
biology to buttress your ethical claims
so here's an example i i talked to
france to wall two weeks ago and that'll
be out soon and he's the world's
greatest living primatologist perhaps um
the the only his only competitor would
be
um
what's his name he wrote catching fire
richard rangham who i also talked to
about a week ago and uh dewalt's work is
unbelievably important it's unbelievably
important
because he's concentrated on the idea of
the alpha male and you know we have in
part popular parlance we have an idea of
the alpha chimp right or the alpha male
for that matter and it's pretty much a
postmodern neo-marxist view of primate
primate sociology and that is that
the biggest ugliest meanest male
dominates by brute force and so now he's
at the top of the pyramid and so the
implicit claim there from the biologists
is that
power
those who express power most effectively
power being the ability to compel
those who express power most effectively
will dominate the
pyramid of of uh
of
of dominance of of social hierarchy and
they'll prevail
reproductively
well that's pretty gloomy
that idea you know but people think well
that's what that's how you look at the
world if you're sensible it's like well
france dewall's been studying chimps for
30 years and that's not true
that is not what happens he told me flat
out that frequently
a small male can become alpha especially
if he has the support of a influential
female
and the small male becomes alpha and has
the support of the influential female
not because he expresses arbitrary power
but because he's unbelievably good at
mutual reciprocation and so he has
friends
and he does things for his friends and
they do things for him and they trust
each other and he has lots of friends
which also means he has no enemies which
turns out to be really important because
the brute chimps
like the psychopath alphas they do rule
now and then but they get torn to shreds
by their enemies because you know
they're tough let's say and mean but
they have an off day and two chimps they
stomped a week before
ally together and tear them literally
tear them into shreds
and so the the psychopath chimp types
who use power to attain dominance get
have very short rules and end in a very
bloody way and so dewall has pointed out
like piaget did among children that
power is an unstable
uh uh ethic upon which to base a social
hierarchy even for chimps and chimps are
male dominated they have a patriarchal
society and they're relatively brutal
and it doesn't even work for them it
certainly doesn't work for human beings
so whatever is at the apex of the
pyramid it's not as the bloody marxists
insist you know the raw expression of
power and and exploitation
wrong
wrong not the case doesn't even work in
nature doesn't work for rats doesn't
work for chimpanzees certainly doesn't
work for people and then there is a kind
of natural ethic that emerges out of
that right because
with rats and with chimps and other
social animals it varies to some degree
from species to species
there's the necessity for something like
mutual reciprocity as the basis for
successful social organization and
that's something like treat your
neighbor
like you would want to be treated it's
something like that it's the behavioral
equivalent of that and you asked earlier
you know
from whence does the highest injunction
emerge or yeah or what comes down yeah
yeah well it's strange right because
some of it's bottom up it's like even
among animals
mutual reciprocity seems to be a
cardinal organizing feature even done in
the spirit of play interestingly enough
because play is a mammalian universal
and that's kind of bottom up but then at
the same time and this this i suppose
pertains to the role of the mysterious
role of consciousness in the world it's
like well we're also aware of this
right and we also we also think about it
abstractly as a good and we don't only
learn it bottom up we also conceptualize
it top down and then they meet and that
is the that's moses coming down the
mountain with the tablets
and and so what did he meet on the
mountain well god well he meant whatever
is at the highest place
and we all
are stuck with the problem of
determining what we are going to put in
the highest place and increasingly i've
been viewing the biblical corpus as an
attempt to
cast narrative light on the nature of
the spirit that should be at the highest
place so i can give you an example of
that so in in the earliest stages of
genesis
god is so what should be in the highest
place remember that's ineffable and
non-utterable in some sense and also
incomprehensible that's that's
technically insisted upon by the
religious types
but whatever it is is it's that which
encounters chaotic potential
and then uses truthful language rooted
in love to extract habitable order
that's what should be in the highest
place and then that's the spirit in
which me
men and women after which men and women
are men and women are fashioned
and you might say well i don't believe
that it's like well i don't know what
you mean when you say that
because like do you believe that people
have intrinsic worth
and you might say no it's like well
is that how you treat the people around
you
because if you don't treat them like
they have intrinsic worth
if they have any sense they're going to
get the hell away from you real fast
right because that's the one thing that
everyone wants is they they want
the relationship they have with another
person to be predicated on mutual
recognition of intrinsic worth
and that's very much tied in the idea of
starting with the idea of the logos that
inhabits us all it's certainly tied in
with the idea of self-evidence in the
declaration of independence the american
declaration of independence you know we
hold these truths as self-evident well
what do you mean self-evident
exactly well part of it is you know
individuals people are fashioned in the
image of god
well i don't believe that well
who says you don't believe that and
maybe you don't but that's not so good
for you and it's certainly not so good
for the people you're interacting with
even if that person happens to be you
because like what's the alternative
people have no intrinsic worth then
you're in dostoevsky in territory it's
like
his book uh crime and punishment because
raskolnikov the protagonist decides that
all this is nonsense right there's no
intrinsic worth there's just power and
so he decides he's going to murder his
landlady who's a really nasty piece of
work and you know he can make a real
good case that
the world would be better without her in
it
and he makes that case she's horrible
she's a horrible person she basically
enslaves her niece and tortures her and
she's like this mentally impaired young
woman and she's a grasping greedy uh
psychopath who makes everyone's life
brutally miserable and so rick
skaltnikov thinks well you know it's the
act of the ubermensch to dispense with
this woman and he lays out the argument
perfectly coherently well it's a
complete bloody catastrophe because he
commits the murder and he get he gets
away with it not really because you
can't
really
and so
that's the pathway and dostoevsky do
this perfectly well he said if there's
no god everything is permitted
you know when modern people especially
the atheist materialist types they look
at that they think well no that isn't
what we mean it's like yeah
maybe you're not dostoevsky you know
like he was a man who could see way down
into the bottom of things and so you
might disagree it's like well fair
enough but you're you and he was
dostoevsky so you know you might wonder
who you should be listening to yeah and
we if you look at historically you can
see that at the first moment when the
let's say the religious ideal starts to
crack you get some positive things like
you know science and the enlightenment
but marquis de sade is right there
waiting to manifest the spirit that
dostoevsky finds in raskolnikov it's
it's there
in terms of sam
one of the things that i haven't heard
you talk about too much but there's
something about what what you said with
him that that brings it up to me is that
he sees this hierarchy or this this is a
religious structure as a totalitarian
impulse it's this kind of structure that
comes down and manifests itself
one of the things that comes down from
the mountain let's say in religious
stories is also compassion
without the hierarchy there is is it
possible for there to be compassion
because compassion is also
the manner in which we accept that
nothing ever reaches the ideal
that we can recognize it but we also
know that it's always kind of beyond us
and so there is a sense that it's
judging us there's also a sense in which
it kind of yields
because
you know every glass is imperfect and
everything every every house is
imperfect every building everything that
we notice or we can also see that it
doesn't reach that ideal i don't know if
you ever thought about that a little bit
well
let me think about that for a second
we've never talked about compassion
before so
yeah well when i when i think about
compassion
i mean first of all i do not believe
that compassion is an untrammeled moral
virtue and i think one of the terrible
things about our society one of the
deadly eatable things about our society
is that we've put compassion in the
highest place unthinkingly and
compassion is for infants
and i really mean that technically so
like if if imagine that that
your ethic was that you were 100
compassionate okay so what are you like
well you're like a good mother with a
child under six months of age
because
because human babies are born
premature in some fundamental sense so
you know the average gestation period
for a mammal of about our size should be
two years and so our babies are born
radically premature and there's complex
reasons for that one is that
there's a arms race an evolutionary arms
race between the circumference of the
infant's head and the dimensions of the
pelvic hole through which the baby has
to pass to be born and if the pelvis of
women was any wider they couldn't run
and if it was any narrower than the
child would die like many children
did right i mean the human birth
mortality rate was abysmal right up
until about well certainly a hundred
years ago and the baby's heads are
compressible right the bones aren't
fully formed when they're born and often
kids are born and their heads are
cone-shaped because they've been subject
to such pressure during birth so it's a
really it's a it's a narrow needle to
thread and there's been a lot of
evolutionary tinkering to get that right
um
now why in the hell did i say that
they're talking about compassion sorry
sorry just
lost my my place compassion right yes
you were talking about the excess of
competitive passion yes yes yes
sorry about that
so so you know our our infants are born
unbelievably helpless
and they are basically
uh
prenatal until they can crawl and that's
say seven or eight months and so prior
to that because they're so utterly
helpless
everything they do has to be regarded as
above moral reproach and 100 right and
so if you have an infant who is crying
who's six months old or four months old
your job is not to judge the infant or
to punish the infant or to discipline
the infant it's like
the infant has a problem and all of your
attention is to be focused on solving
that problem period 100 that's it and
that's great
for people who are under six months
but it's deadly
it's increasingly deadly as the child
matures because that kind of
all-encompassing i will do everything
for you is also the enemy of development
and that's that's the whole freudian
nightmare i mean that's what freud put
his finger on and he knew that that was
the pathology of the age the eatable
mother and it's like yeah well welcome
to the age of the eatable mother
everyone because that's certainly what
we see now and so if you put compassion
in the highest place well then that's
what you have is you have a state of
being where everything is an infant and
the only hallmark of ethic is pity now
jung talked about
classic conceptions of what is in the
highest place god he said well god rules
with two hands mercy
and justice
and that's that discrimination you know
how bad discrimination is it's like well
no it's not it's differentiation it's
judgment it's it's putting things in
their proper place it's it's setting the
highest above the lowest it's it's
formulating a pathway for further
development and you know a mother might
say you're just
fine the way you are but what's that to
say to someone who's
well 10. it's like you're not fine the
way you are you're 10. you've got a lot
of growing up to do and you're probably
not fine the way you are when you're 20.
it's like you're just a fraction of what
you could be and if it's all maternal
compassion and and i mean that in the
symbolic sense it's all maternal
compassion it's where's the impetus for
development and there's no
judgment there and i think the most
dismal thing you can tell 18 year old
boys in particular especially if they're
miserable is well you're just okay the
way you are and you're they're not first
of all and no one thinks they are
including them
well they don't not no one gives a damn
about
malfunctioning 18 year old boys like
[Applause]
you know but you but you can say with
the proper admixture of justice and
mercy it's like yeah well you know
you're not so bad for 18. and and you
could be way more and good for you and
then you can encourage that and and
that's a that's the spirit of justice
and that's a patriarchal spirit
fundamentally it's the encouragement and
the calling forth of further development
and so
you could see it like in terms of we
bring it back to something very ground
like very technical which is
walking down the street and so i'm
walking from this point to that point
and there is a perfect way which i could
get there but i if i do that i might
spend all my time trying to figure what
that out and i might not even be able to
move there's also a man in which i could
go anywhere and fall over so there has
to be even in
almost every act of perception that
right hand and left hand that you talk
right right that mercy and justice has
to have heart there has to be allowance
for imperfection and error
well
well
also
also orientation towards the aim yeah
and and getting that balance right well
that's part of what consciousness does i
would say is it constantly adjudicates
between those two higher order
principles now those aren't the only
principles but and that and there's no
final solution to that right you can't
just say well we're all compassionate
and we're done with it's like no and
it's it's an ongoing problem right with
your kids you're always wondering
they make a mistake it's well how much
do you forgive them and how much do you
say you know how about you don't do that
again it's really embarrassing it's
terrible for you if you replicate that
error your life is going to be a bloody
catastrophe you're old enough to figure
it out it's like clue in and you might
say well who loves the child more the
one who says oh it's okay everything you
do is lovely which it isn't or or the
person who says you could do better
and you know the answer is well it's
it's a discussion between those two
viewpoints constantly constantly because
and and and in your relationship with
yourself it's like how much do you
forgive yourself and the answer
certainly is zero it's not zero that's
no one can live without being able to
forgive themselves to some degree but by
the same token you know you don't want
to let yourself off the hook for every
idiot error you make
and because that just doesn't work
because there are real errors and yeah
there are cons real consequences yes for
you and other people and yeah and and
there's and there's the real which you
know we're all wondering about now this
is one of the things that i think is
quite comical and i talked to dawkins
about this is you know
um
the the
rationalists the scientists the atheists
and the postmodernists as well really
took the idea of the divine to pieces
and even in the dismissive way that you
see with someone say like harris
although like i said he has his
meditation and his he dwells in the
realm of the sacred he just leaves it
ineffable right and doesn't ritualize it
doesn't turn it into any kind of
intellectual creed and i think he he
does that because if he turned it into
an intellectual creed his rationality
would just tear it to pieces
and so then he would have nothing you
know um
on in any case
um
we've dispensed with the idea of the
sacred transcendent let's say and that's
the hard-headed way of thinking about
the world but what the
what the uh
the reductive atheists didn't quite
figure out was the dostoevsky problem
it's like well if there's no god
everything is permitted well how about
we don't believe in objects anymore
well that won't happen it's like yeah
really that won't happen eh what makes
you think that like do the buddhists
believe in objects not really
you know the world's maya it's illusion
there's no transcendent material world
that's a western idea and i really think
it came out of well partly greece but
certainly came out of ideas that are
associated with the logos on the logic
side and on the out on the religious
side it's like there's a transcendent
world it's material it's transcendent
world
you can't just do any old thing
you will be
the object of world will object to what
you're doing and so then it's an
inexhaustible source of corrective
wisdom and it's the it's the realization
of that in some sense that's
the precondition for science you have to
believe that before you can be a
scientist there's a reality out there
that transcends your knowledge and the
postmodern types i mean
technically they just rejected that
completely they collapsed ontology which
is the study of being let's say into
epistemology said no it's all it's all
words
it's like oh i see so we stopped
believing in god now we stop believing
in the object and if you're wondering
why the dei types are taken on the stem
people
if you haven't noticed that and are
going to win by the way it's because
they don't believe in the objective
world what the hell you need scientists
for
you know that's there's no objective
reality it's just whim
people can't believe that's like that's
what people have believed for most of
time and
what do you mean they can't believe that
you mean until the bridges start falling
down
they'll just blame that on insufficient
diversity
yeah it'd be funny if it wasn't true
i mean i think we are in uh we're in a
kind of we're in a moment there's this
zeitgeist there's this change that's
happened you've been part of it
definitely where suddenly people are
starting to realize this and i think
it's it's also going together with the
extremity of the
the madness of the ideologues and and
that's exactly it that we are at a point
where objective reality itself or
mathematics themselves are being
questioned by ideologues where two plus
two equals five where people are arguing
for these types of things and
how do we
exactly how do we come back to that
without
let's say bringing about this notion
this incarnational principle we could
say right that even things that we
encounter in the world they are
embodiments of embedded in higher truth
you could say that they kind of scale up
and that there is a there's a
flexibility to it right it's not it's
not hard but that flexibility is part of
how we engage with it yeah yeah well as
far as i can tell and i mean i think
this is happening to some degree in the
culture is that i mean
jung believed carl jung believed and he
was the wisest psychologist i've ever
read by a large margin he certainly
believed that
we had to delve so jung was a student of
nietzsche i don't mean he you know
formally but
he was
very well versed in nietzsche in
thinking
as much or more so than in freudian
thinking and he really devoted his life
to addressing a proposition that
nietzsche put forward and nietzsche said
well god is dead and we have killed him
and we'll never find the water to wash
away the blood you know the holiest that
we have created has now died at our own
hands and he thought that was an
absolute catastrophe
because nietzsche was a very smart man
and a very wise man
but he made a real error i believe and
and he he posited that
because of this collapse of values this
precipitous collapse of the the value
that unifies all values or that is the
precondition for all values that
we would be lost he certainly felt that
we would fall into nihilism or that we
would fall prey to communist idolatry in
particular which he predicted dead on
just like dostoevsky did but then he
also said that the solution to that will
be that the superman will have to appear
the ubermensch and he will be that the
man who can create his own values and so
both freud and jung were interested in
that idea um freud more peripherally
but yield more
more consciously and part of what jung
was trying to find out is
well could we create our own values
and the answer he came up with was no
that's not possible and why
so the question is why well you know for
the psychoanalysts
we were beset by fantasies and these are
sort of autonomous personalities that
dwell in in our subconscious let's say
in our imagination in our dreams and
that possess us from time to time the
spirit of rage the spirit of lust
the spirit of envy um these ancient gods
that possess us and uh
these values that and temptations and
impulses that come upon us
that we cannot control
they're part of our autonomous nature
and
because they have this autonomy
and so that would be the autonomy of
emotions and the autonomy of motivations
and then
even the autonomy of the spirit that
unites motivations because we don't know
for example in the spirit of play for
example play is an instinct
play
integrates
base motivations into a higher unity but
it's an instinct
and so jung realized very rapidly that
it wasn't technically possible for us to
create our own values and that's partly
his
stumbling upon the problem of complexity
so the world's just too complex for us
to generate our values
in the span of a single life out of
whole cloth
autonomously no matter how much of a
superman we were yeah and that partly
the reason that's impossible is well
okay so generate your own values what
the hell are you gonna do with your wife
or your husband or your friend they're
what are they gonna they're just gonna
live by your values all of a sudden well
that's what the post-modernists are
demanding now the radical types is like
my game right my identity i'm whatever i
say i am moment to moment and and
there's no negotiation and that's
because they're two years old and
i mean that
i mean that i i mean i mean that i mean
that i mean that technically i mean one
of the things i learned partly from
reading freud freud had this idea of
developmental fixation and he noticed in
his clients and his patients that people
would get stuck at a developmental level
and so you'd be talking to an adult and
all of a sudden they were four years old
and i learned to see that in my clients
and well and people i talk to i'll do
that with if they're annoying me um
you know like okay who the hell are you
oh i see you're a 13 year old mean girl
okay away we go i know who i'm talking
to now and these these these solipsistic
identity
uh uh totalitarians are two years old
and two-year-olds are
um
very governed by emotion they're
completely incapable of negotiation
they're egotistical in that their
worldview dominates they have no notion
whatsoever of
of negotiated play and their belief is
their identity is 100
generated by them dependent on what they
feel moment to moment which is exactly
how a two-year-old operates and most of
them get socialized out of that by the
age of four and those that don't have a
very dismal time of it after that
so and i think we have a lot of people
like that now because screens have
interfered with pretend play and
negotiation and because
edible parents
and
and social systems have produced
have enabled a kind of immature
narcissism that makes itself manifest in
these absurd claims about identity and
that's all part of creating your own
values i can be whatever sex i want to
be moment to moment it's like
fine
but
how
how are other people
supposed to deal with that because they
don't know what to do well it doesn't
matter they have to do exactly what i
want them to it's like hey good luck
with that you and you superman you
ubermensch with your own values
and this is also partly why
the liberals the small l liberal types
are wrong in a fundamental sense and
this would include most therapists it's
like
you might think of identity in a and and
of sanity itself as sort of an internal
psychological arrangement you know so
you have your act together it's sort of
in your brain or in your psyche and
you're saying and there's insane people
around you but you're saying it's like
that isn't really right it's sort of
right but
you know you're saying if
if you if you're uh what a reciprocal
partner in your marriage
you're saying if you have three or four
friendships that you've been able to
maintain because you can act
reciprocally and the sanity is actually
the balance between you
and you and your wife or husband and
then you and your wife or husband and
your friends or you and your wife and
your husband um or your husband
and your children and your friends and
your larger family it's and it's this
nested thing that we already talked
about it's like you can't be sane in the
absence of that because that's actually
the definition of sanity and it's
collective as well as that's why the
kingdom of god is within you and without
you it's exactly that it's like yeah you
have a harmonious psyche but
you know are you dancing with yourself
to music that no one else can hear
that's not helpful there's a communal
element of it that has to be in place
and so if you're saying
your marriage is saying and you have
sane relationships with your children
you have sane relationships with your
friends and you're a good employee or a
boss and you're a participant in the
civic world and all of that is
embedded in this hierarchy that has
the spirit at the top that enables that
reciprocity to operate and you're a
devotee of that yeah or you're not
right and so yeah and that's the
religious domain and you have to
actively celebrate at the different
levels that you participate in that you
know and i think that's where i i kind
of bring it back to the
to helping people understand like
some why do people go to church
right because that's what's going on why
should they because that's a discussion
so jonathan took me to an orthodox uh
um uh
ceremony in seattle
and uh
like i wasn't into it um
i i found it
it grated on me um you're like a
ten-year-old boy that we're telling to
stop moving yeah yeah that's right so
that was my freudian fixations like
you're a tan
wiggly yeah yes
no kidding
no kidding but um you know there's been
a lot of water under the bridge since
then man and i went to an orthodox uh
mass here a couple of weeks ago and i
found it unbel and a catholic one a week
before that i was down at uh franciscan
university and i found it unbelievably
soothing which is very much unlike the
reactions i've had before and that was
partly well for complicated reasons
because i actually find any place that
isn't a bloody nightmarish catastrophe
soothing now and so
i mean that man and but there was more
to it than that too it was because i i
also did develop and partly as a
consequence of our discussions a deeper
appreciation for
what was happening in the ritual itself
and
and also more tolerance for whatever
inadequacies i might perceive you know
partly that's also realization you know
lots of modern people say why don't go
to church because i don't believe that
it's like
well a who cares what you believe like
who the hell are you anyways
like and why do you even care what you
believe and how is that working for you
this belief set that you theoretically
have is how sophisticated is that like
you see are you plato or what it's like
well here's the church and here's me and
i'm right it's like well no you're not
and first and second you don't even want
to be because that's a great place to be
like pinnacle of brilliant wisdom it's
completely solipsistic no tradition for
me thank you very much you know i've got
it all right in my head and even if you
are right that the bloody institution is
chaotic
and and and uh
decadent in some fundamental sense it's
like well good there's something for you
to do like there always has been
throughout the entire history of mankind
because that's osiris right the
once great king who's fallen into
disrepair it's like well if the church
is broken
and you're the genius to see it
why do you go fix it well then you might
say well we'll just abandon it it's like
okay well
fine you're going to get rid of that are
you're going to get rid of marriage
you're going to get rid of funerals
you're going to get rid of christmas
you're going to get rid of any sense of
sacred time you're going to dispense
with the whole history of what
judeo-christian thought
you're going to dispense with the idea
of the sacred nature of the individual
like how far are you willing to go with
this and believe me that question is
right in front of you because there's a
wave of radicals who are asking you at
every moment
what makes you so sure that there's a
difference between a man and a woman
like
no there isn't
or yes there is when we want there to be
and no there isn't when we don't want
her to be you saw that with the supreme
court um
appointment it's like we have to have a
woman
but there's no such thing as a woman
it's like
and so yeah
you
you frenchman you know you've you've
abandoned your catholicism you think the
catholics they were crazy it's like you
ain't seen nothing yet
and so i'd believe and jung kind of
convinced me of that he he more or less
posited and you could say the same thing
about orthodox he said catholic is as
insane as people ever get and that's
partly because we have to have one foot
in the
dream
and the mystery we have to you know when
i i heard douglas murray speak recently
about this that was very interesting
because murray
is an atheist essentially and he has a
variety of reasons for that but he has
swung around hard recently and he said
when he was talking to dave rubin he
said
i don't believe that either conservatism
or classic liberalism can survive in the
absence of the of the religious surround
which was really something for him to
admit and it's like taking him like five
years of thinking to come to that
conclusion but then he said something
even more remarkable i thought and he
said and it's actually the mysterious
part of it that has to be retained the
virgin birth the resurrection the
crucifixion all of that crazy mythology
let's say because otherwise it just
degenerates into another
form of cheap social justice and like
don't we have enough of that
and i think that's
now i don't know what to make of that
because well and that's why we have
discussion continually about
the
what would you say
well the transcendent i suppose the
miraculous the transcendent the idea of
the resurrection for example and all of
that it's like well what do you do with
that and the answer is
we don't know but we don't throw it out
without
having some sense of what's going to
come in to replace it
and we're seeing that now you know look
at us we're so confused no bloody one of
the russians are at war with us it's
like
we're not having anything to do those
people
they simultaneously proclaim that a
woman is absolutely necessary for the
highest position in the land or one of
them and that the same person says
well i don't even know what a woman is
it's like well are those people insane
it's like clearly
clearly that's just way too far right
when i talk to my democrat friends i say
look you can have one of those
you know there's either no distinction
between a man or a woman
or it's important that a woman is on the
supreme court but there's no bloody way
i'm giving you both
so because i don't even know how to do
that i have no idea how to do that like
what am i supposed to do celebrate
womanhood
and simultaneously celebrate the fact
that the differences between men and
women are so trivial that they're
irrelevant and they can be changed at
web that is insane
it violates the law of non-contradiction
and so
there's no
that's
you think religious people are crazy
jesus
want to take questions
well that's a funny place to stop so i
think we will stop there and we have
some audience questions and so if you if
you
would like then
we'll we'll we'll switch to that
and so
thanks jonathan that was just fine
[Applause]
all right and so this is the first time
i deal with this thing so hopefully i'll
do okay
um and so people from the audience were
bringing in questions
so esteban asks i'm a i am raising three
kids one boy and two girls as a young
father are there differences in the kind
of advice i should give my son and my
daughters
yes definitely
you know because boys and girls aren't
the same
um
so advice
well i can i can tell you about my
discussion with france to wall again
because i think that's germaine and we
might as well keep this concrete
dewalt has just written a book called
different
and in that book he
assesses the
clear and marked differences in
in
motivational preference between
boys and girls but also between male
primates and female primates especially
chimpanzees who are our closest
biological relative and you can
calculate that by looking at genetic
similarity and
those things are calculated with an
incredible degree of accuracy
um female chimps young ones for example
if you give them a block of wood
they'll frequently put the block of wood
on their back and carry it around
and and cuddle it and
and take care of it as if it's an infant
so they infantilize objects which
you know human females do
at the drop of a hat
and
the male chimps if you give them a
if you give a female chimp a doll or a
teddy bear something like that they'll
they treat it like a human female treats
a doll they'll take care of it and
nurture it and develop an attachment to
it and uh they respond very badly if you
know maybe they trust the keeper say and
they'll give the keeper the doll and if
the keeper isn't good to the doll
they're
not happy and that's a bad idea because
chimpanzees are very strong so you don't
want to make them angry and so but if
you give
the male juveniles a doll they'll just
tear it apart see what's inside
and so
you know and and that's that's basically
what they do with monkeys because the
male chimps juveniles will hunt columbus
monkeys they weigh about 40 pounds and
they tear them into pieces and eat them
and chimps are ravenous when it comes to
meat and so and in that manner they're
also like us because they are hunters
and they also go to war and it's the
males who do that and the chimp males
they
if you give them
cars or dolls to play with they will
pick the cars now that's pretty weird
right because you know
chimps and hondas there
[Laughter]
they just haven't invented hondas you
know but there's something about the
gadget quality of the car that appeals
to the tool use interest of the mail
and one of the most reliable differences
between males and female humans is
different in interest not competence not
ability but interest and
males are more reliably interested in
things and females are more reliably
interested in
people and that's a big difference so
you would have to be
at the 85th percentile
as a man for interest in people to be as
interested in people as the average 50th
percentile woman
and you'd have to be at the 85th
percentile among females interest in
things
to be as interested in things as the
average male and the reason why in the
scandinavian countries there's a
preponderance of male engineers and a
preponderance of female nurses and that
that differential has increased as the
scandinavian countries have become more
egalitarian is because that intrinsic
interest is fundamentally biological and
so if you make the society egalitarian
it maximizes rather than decreasing and
of course social constructionist
uh
postmodernist marxist types just hate
that because it implies that there's
some sort of limit
necessary limit on their social
engineering it applies that human beings
have an intrinsic nature that
that nature is
that there's a female nature and a male
nature which is so weird because this is
another sign of our insanity it's like
there's no difference between men and
women
at all and if there is and there isn't
it's only cultural unless
you're a
girl who's trapped in a boy's body in
which case the difference is all of a
sudden so important that it has to be
mediated biologically and any objection
to that is illegal it's like
which is all the case at the moment and
so that's also insane because
sorry you get one you don't get both
there's either differences and they're
important or there aren't there aren't
both
and so
well okay so back to the kids
um
well
you know
it's it's important to see that there
are
okay when i was talking to d wall he he
uh he cited this female author who had
forbidden her boy to have guns
and she was quite annoyed about this
because the little rat
made guns out of everything out of soap
out of he chased the cat around with the
toothbrush you know going bang bang bang
bang and she said she like threw her
hands up in dismay and and and i thought
you evil witch it's like you've done and
she said i did everything i could to
dissuade my son's interest in guns it's
like yeah you did everything you could
all right and it still didn't work and
that wasn't good enough for you because
you know despite the fact that that's
your son and that's what he's like
your morality your ideological morality
is going to take precedence and you're
going to crush that out of him you're
going to throw up your hands in moral
despair because your boy isn't
the figment of your bloody eatable
imagination it's a appalling
and so
back to the girls they're going to want
to do girl things likely and maybe
you'll have some girls that are a little
more masculine they'll be a little bit
more tomboyish and that's just look fine
there's plenty of temperamental
variation between boys and girls but you
know it's important to know that they're
going to have these difference in
interests and you want to
you want to
you want to foster that or at least
allow it you know so your girls are
gonna they're gonna play with dolls
and
they're going to have female toy
preferences in all likelihood
and your boys the same way and if you
have any sense
you won't
punish that you know you might shape it
mold it if you have a boy who's
aggressive some boys about five percent
of two-year-old boys are kick hit bite
and steal they're aggressive most of
them are socialized by the age of four
you can channel that aggressiveness that
competitiveness you can socialize it you
know you can you can make it pro-social
which is what you should do but
you know
your kid isn't
nothing they haven't people have a
nature an intrinsic nature and it's up
to you to foster that and to direct it
and to
and to have some respect for it you know
both on the feminine and the masculine
side
so
and you
all right this is a question that i've
never heard you
try to answer and so let's see how this
goes
[Applause]
please make us happy okay i understood
the question i don't know if that makes
you happy or not
that's right it would be lovely if you
understood a little bit of friends would
you we would like to hear you speak no
you can't
yeah you know when i when i came here
when i came here from alberta i had
always wanted to come to montreal i was
a fan of the montreal canadiens from the
time i was a little kid and i always
dreamed
yvonne cornway and uh and yeah yeah
henri richard and yeah it was great and
i always dreamed of coming to montreal i
always knew i was going to come to
montreal from the time i was like 12.
and
i wanted to learn to speak french and i
took french and alberta but that was
like impossible because
our french teachers could speak french
you know so
that was impossible and uh
i came here with every intent to learn
to speak french but i wrote my book maps
of meaning and i published a bunch of
articles and i really concentrated on
what i was doing at mcgill and that went
by the wayside and i really regret it
because
you know i had that opportunity and i
can
more or less understand it's spoken if
the person who's speaking isn't very
bright and speaks slowly
and i can sort of read french but my
spoken french is abysmal and
embarrassingly so and so and i do regret
that because this is i loved this city
it was a great place to live
uh i had a great time at mcgill my my
advisor robert peel is here somewhere in
the audience um and he was a wonderful
advisor and as i said the uh the
co-author of the self-authoring program
and
um
i love this city and there's something
about montreal culture that's it's so
it was so cool to come here from alberta
because everyone moved to alberta it's a
new place you know it has no history and
there's some advantage in that but
people live in montreal and has a real
culture you know and people live out on
the streets
and there's a vibrancy to the culture
here that's such fun and although you
have kind of a fascistic bureaucracy
it's it's uh
yeah
it's uh but the city itself is so free
and it's so peaceful there's no crime to
speak of the streets are safe you could
go anytime anywhere you want day or
night the comedy festival is great the
jazz festival is great the the the
spontaneous celebrations in montreal if
soccer team wins a victory there's a
spirit of joy there's none of that
malevolence that you feel in in the
center of american cities often for
example that sort of lurking danger this
is an amazing place and i really hope we
don't muck it up you've done a lovely
job on the waterfront
so
you know and i i feel too that you know
i had no obligation in some sense as a
canadian to to become bilingual and to
do that fluently and that just didn't
happen and it's it's uh it's a regret
that's for sure so my apologies so do
you wanna keep wanna go do another one
pretty good yeah yeah all right let's do
two more says do two more all right and
so
um all right i got one here this is a
tough one too
you often use but i like you that's why
you often use post-modern marxism as a
catch-all term for wokeness can you
explain what you mean considering both
schools of thoughts are diametrically
opposed like like the postmodernists
care about that like i just hate this
criticism it's like well you know they
were contradictory it's like yes
actually i do know do they
know
and you say well you know they're
diametrically opposed it's like yes i
know that because the postmodernists are
skeptical of grand narratives and
marxism is a grand narrative let's point
that out okay so then why were all the
french post-modernist marxists because
they didn't care about coherence how
about that or how about maybe they were
trying to justify their own narcissistic
drive to power how about that you
explain it
why are all the french intellectuals
marxists in the 1960s and 1970s until
solzhenitsyn published
the gulag archipelago in which case they
were still marxists they just went
underground because they're all so
embarrassed as they should have been
you know sartre marxist communist
dereda
foucault darida wrote a book on the
relationship between his philosophy and
marxism right it's not my imagination
and so people say well don't you know
that there's a contradiction it's like
you think you think deconstruction is
care about contradictions that's how
much you understand about
deconstructionism it's like they don't
care about contradictions at all
it's irrelevant and why did they
do why did they what would you say sort
of
divert towards marxism or or
default default towards marxism
i don't know maybe because
academics are jealous of rich people i
don't bloody well know well i've seen
that among academics you know they're
hyper intelligent generally speaking and
competent in their domain but they don't
make that much money compared to rich
people and that irritates them a lot and
so what do they do well they criticize
capitalism it's like
well they're completely 100 percent
protected by capitalism they're the most
protected people the world of it has
ever generated and unbelievably
ungrateful
and they want to have the their
intellect and the protection of the
capitalist system and simultaneously
befriend to the poor and i've watched
what sort of friend to the poor most
left-wing academics are and i can tell
you man you have a friend like that you
don't need an enemy
so
so it's like it's like it's like
foucault and and derek that's like well
we don't believe in grand narratives
except for marxism it's like that's real
convenient boys
and and has anybody pointed out the
contradiction well you know us french
intellectuals we don't talk about that
it's like yeah no kidding you don't talk
about it because it's scandalous to say
the least to be a marxist to be a
marxist now
really
after
what 120 million deaths how much bloody
evidence do you need
and the answer is i'm so arrogant that
all those corpses make no difference to
me
and that's the answer
so
yes i'm perfectly aware that the
deconstructionists and the marxists
exist at odds with one another
so but they do have something very uh
similar in common which is that they
both
see the notion that quantity devours
quality
that the mass
takes over the hierarchy and that we
destroy invert subvert any form
hierarchical yes that's true that and
that's that's a good observation yeah so
you see that in daredevil right because
there it is all for derek uh western
culture was foul logo centric which is
exactly the case you just made right
that we have something at the center and
that it's hierarchical and it's
patriarchal it's like he's right about
that and we should bring the margins in
that's darada's idea because he's a
clown a fundamental i mean he's a joker
really i mean that he's he's a he's a
he's a trickster daredevil right to the
core absolutely 100
and he's full of tricks and that's one
of the tricks is to bring the margins
into the center and he knew perfectly
well that if you bring the margins to
the center you just have a new margin
which is why we have christian satirists
now like the babylon bee you know it's
because everything's upside down yeah
and so the of tiffany
could predict no i don't think so either
i don't think so either it's like when
did the christians become funny
when the world turned upside down that's
right
well it's so weird it's like because
i've i've watched the babylon bee guys
and i watched their interview with you
which was like the weirdest interview
i've ever seen in my life these crazy
frat boy
christian fundamentalists which is weird
enough in itself
interviewing you about sacred
architecture and
monstrous gargoyles in renaissance
architecture and the relationship
between that and cognitive
categorization and then making like
weird frat boy jokes the whole bloody
time while you were keeping up with some
producer laughing maniacally in the
background it's like oh wow so this is
where our culture's at
so it was strange but
all right one last canadian question so
gabriel v asks do you believe that pia
poliev could be the next prime minister
of canada
[Laughter]
[Applause]
you know i've been watching the
conservative party federally since i was
a kid it's a long time now like so i've
been watching them with some degree of
interest for
50 years and they always do this they
almost always do the same thing when
when it comes to leadership selection
they'll have a candidate who's got a bit
of a spine and this is independent of
what you think of him or his policies
polio has a spine
and
then so they have a candidate with a
spine and he's got a little bit of spark
and then they have a leadership
convention and
people are alienated by him because of
his spine and also because he's a victor
and so
and he'll have an opponent and people
are opposed to him and then there'll be
a third candidate who doesn't annoy
anyone
like joe clark
and
then that's who they'll elect and so
then we just have a we just have a
sequence of
these leaders for the conservatives who
the liberals can just and the radicals
can just chase around non-stop and who
try not to offend anyone and who are
embarrassed about being conservative and
that's probably what the conservatives
will do again because that's what they
do and that's what canada does and so
you know we could easily could we have
trudeau for eight more years god yeah
well
we sure could we certainly gonna have
him for two or three years unless he
implodes and that's some that is
which i doubt because you know
in the last six months the trudeau
government has done
i would say 10 things so scandalous that
when i was younger 20 to 30 to 40 maybe
even any single one of those things
would have brought down a government and
he's just doing like one a week
and so and and nothing happens
and
you know
he doesn't refer to parliament oh well
parliament what was that it's just
annoying you know the chinese communists
they have it right they're going to
impose those environmental policies with
with no discussion and that's what we'd
like because that's what we admire who
cares about parliament we can freeze
bank accounts we can lie about the
truckers we can subsidize state media so
that now we have a fascistic collusion
between government and media and if you
don't think that's true it's like well
you do think that's true because
otherwise you wouldn't be here
and so so what would i say about pierre
pauliev well he had enough guts to come
on my youtube channel and you know i
didn't give him any questions beforehand
zero there was no preparation
um
we didn't do any post hoc editing and he
didn't ask for any
he answered all the questions i asked
him with no
prevarication you know there was a few
kind of prepared political talking
points
and uh but
i thought he handled himself extremely
well he was a very good
conversationalist he could really take
turns into conversation he was
thoughtful
i believe that his care for
working-class people is genuine i think
his economic policy is unsophisticated
to the point of
um
would you say danger insufficiency and
i've talked to some very sophisticated
economic players in the canadian market
and they believe that our basic legal
framework and our economic framework is
40 years out of date and these are
people who've
played
let's say on the international
market and got burned badly by
hyper
qualified american legal experts who
just tore them into shreds when they
tried to compete you know on broad scale
in international markets we don't have
good policies for data ownership in
canada we're way out of sync with the
digital age we have no idea what we
should be owning and what we shouldn't
be owning in in terms of our our
personal information our data and it
isn't obvious that polio has the
sophistication to develop those policies
but i think he would
and could learn and he's young he's only
in his early 40s
and uh i think he would be willing to
repair our relationship with the united
states too and maybe do something
quasi-intelligent on the energy front
which would be you know kind of
delightful and maybe he'd defund the cbc
and christ we should vote for him for
just for that
yeah because the faster they go the
better the better
1.2 billion dollars a year to generate
zero audience and to lie and to lie to
their funders so that he can continue to
believe all the idiot things he believes
it's really quite something i don't know
if polyeth can manage it you know i mean
the legacy media hates him yeah and uh
yeah maybe that's a good thing because
lots of people hate the legacy media so
yeah
you know
i i think not no i can't do that yeah
because we have a procedure and you know
i'm a conservative so all right i sort
of all right all right thank you great
thank you very much everyone thanks
jonathan
thank you all
pleasure to see you all here
yeah hopefully it won't be five years
before i show up again so yeah yeah
thank you
all right
yeah
such a good looking crowd
good night thanks man